welcome back to las vegas now well
memorial day is this weekend and that
marks the unofficial start to summer and
joining us to share his summer
essentials sponsored by taylormade
productions is entertaining expert paul
zahn how are you good how are you i'm
ready for some summer parties some of
you know whenever you show up i know
we're about to have a good time moves
food everything actually speak in my
language so let's get right to it i'm
seeing a food in the corner over here
what are we talking about yes so smart
and final has you covered for all your
home entertaining needs for all summer
especially memorial day weekend they
have the big club sizes but without the
club membership fee which we love so
this can last all summer and they also
have sun harvest which is their organic
line that's a better price point than
some of the other organic lines out
there so you can do you know summer
meals made easy and you can also have
this delivered if you go to
smartenfinal.com it is one click and
that's it and that's your food oh my
gosh i didn't know that you could get it
delivered i love hawaiian rolls so you
can get a big pack over there that's my
go-to for any holiday okay but to go
along with food we need drinks yes
japanese whiskeys are super popular
right now so we have some hattazaki
finest japanese whiskey so this is a
blend of whiskeys that include 40
minimum of malt whiskies and it is aged
12 years in barrel so what does that
mean it means it yields a delicious
japanese whiskey that you can make some
great summer cocktails you can do a high
ball which is some soda water here and
you can pick this up at total wine and
this makes a great father's day gift so
get dad some hatasaki japanese whiskey i
was just thinking about what i should
get my dad for father's day that's a
great great idea and i love this straw
has little watermelons on it summer's
here summer's here
okay let's move on what do we have in
front of us here we have some hair care
by wow skin science so this is a red
onion black seed oil
shampoo and conditioner yes you hear red
onion you think it's going to smell like
red onion it does not it smells
wonderful so the shampoo is actually
going to get into your roots and help
with hair loss and everything like that
the conditioner is really going to
breathe new life into your hair give it
that moisture hydration it's 100 vegan
no sulfates it's wonderful and it's
under 30 you can get that at um pure wow
science.com wow okay well out here in
the desert we need something that
hydrates absolutely it's so dry here
right okay and i know that pillowcases
are really important but i don't know
much about them so tell me all about it
well we have blissey today so blissey is
a full line of loungewear pillowcases
eye mask face mask it's 100 mulberry
silk it feels like butter if you touch
it you'll see it feels like butter it's
hypoallergenic oh my god it's going to
help with aging on your face less
wrinkles it's going to help with less
hair breakage and everything like that
and it has 70 thousand verified reviews
online so people love they're blissey
and you can find out more information
about blissey at blissey.com you know
what's funny i think someone gave me
this as a gift and i have this at home
and i've never used it before so can i
try it you can try it on it is
i
yeah
i need to feel like feel this material
on my face so this is going to like wow
detox
i cannot see you yes you can see nothing
so we have some detox and then we have
some retards we have drinks food
pillowcases we have shampoo we have
everything covered right well hopefully
my hair is okay after that this is worth
it no breakage there's been no breakage
so yeah ready for the holiday weekend
thank you to you paul all of these are
such great great things to incorporate
over the weekend or any time of year
heading into summer so thank you paul so
much
and um you got to come back for whatever
holiday is next i'm sure you're always
our birthday
paul thank you jc i'll send it over to
you